we want to take you now behind the
scenes at Bloomberg oh right here where
we've been asking legends from the
corporate world for some insight what
advice would they give to their 18-year
old selves if they had the opportunity
take a listen I think loving what you do
and working hard at what you do are the
two best things that you can do and when
you cease to love it find something else
don't worry so much about being right be
right do your analysis but be effective
so many times we get lost in being right
and not being effective and then we
actually leave it up to the effective
people that are wrong so it would be try
to be effective within the bounds of
reasonable business as well as being
right and figuring things out the best
advice I would give anybody is don't go
into a field for money go into a field
because you have a passion about what
that field entails in terms of activity
stated slightly differently i tell the
youngsters I speak with where I would
tell myself at age 18 do what you love
love what you do is if you do what you
love and you love what you do you're
bound to be successful guess my biggest
advice is be aware that there will be
setbacks and it's all about how you
respond to them so when I was 18 I
thought life was just a linear
progression from one stage to the next
and I've learned it takes a more
interesting path than that do what you
enjoy find what you what you want to
spend your time doing and then focus on
it and when I say focus on it it doesn't
mean trying to become the CEO when
you're 18 it means actually spending the
time heads down and really trying to
learn and understand the business and
making that investment in your future as
opposed to focusing on kind of the end
result that early on okay so what advice
would you give you a general self Eric
oh gosh uh it wasn't that long a lot
about it I'll tell you what I would say
I mean I followed some of that advice
which was choose nothing for the sake of
money with yeah that's how I'll tell you
I'm sure analyst I've learned it would
just make mistakes I'm not sure I've
ever learned from a success that I've
had but I've learned a lot from mistakes
it's made me better and stronger so
actually make that sort of a rally
cries you know for the millennial
generation as well right don't be afraid
to fail yeah well I believe it's just in
my own personal clearly not being afraid
to fail is easier said than done yeah
and the main thing is just to learn from
a mistake you make the open to it
realizes a mistake don't be defensive
what would you advise her 18-year old
self beyond that the greatest thing
actually I found as I've gotten older is
the older i am the less I know at 18 I
knew everything today there's just so
much left to learn I love it actually I
love the just being here and learning
from you it's great business it is a
great business to be and we're very
fortunate